they get some help potentially this
weekend against the lions michael thomas
who
suffered a high ankle sprain week one
against the buccaneers returned to
practice on wednesday
will that make a difference if michael
thomas comes back and assuming that he
can move
like he always has and he's not
diminished in some way
it's definitely going to make a
difference there's no doubt it's just
it's another element that a defense has
to worry about right
to where it's just going to make other
things easier within the offense
and then really the beauty of michael
thomas and like the vision of what
sean payton did i think here in drafting
him is he realized hey drew is not a big
armed guy at that point of his career
not throwing balls down the field
michael thomas really
fits the way sean payton wants to run
the offense with drew
and drew as we saw in our you know spray
chart early this week where he throws
the football and things like that
he lives over the middle right around
the hashes 10 yards and in
and michael thomas is a junkyard dog
there he kicks butt
all day long and just works linebackers
and safeties and corners
and is tough in zone coverages so yes he
will help out the other thing too mike
just to say it because the guy was just
on with camara i mean to me
damn they just paid him all this money
start letting him tote the rock
run the ball more i mean 12 and 13
carries and eight carries and things
like that
damn he's too good he needs to touch the
ball more i mean from what we've seen
the last few weeks of him running
between the tackles
i think both you and i sit there and go
holy crap he looks like you know
i mean he's playing with just great
intensity and
vision and play-making ability i mean
they need to get in the ball more
yeah but that's the balance you got to
keep him healthy the way the saints have
always handled their running backs it's
been multiple and
he's being paid in part to be a receiver
even though it's mainly in the short
passing game
because that's where he does a lot of
his damage his 52-yard
touchdown the other night was on a catch
not on a handoff
you don't want to bang him into the
tackles over and over again because
that's when you run the risk of him
getting injured and if
they don't have alvin kamara they really
are in trouble the
49ers are going to get back one of their
injured players who hasn't been
available for the last two games george
kittle suffered a knee injury on a
hospital ball thrown by jimmy garoppolo
week one i mean it was he threw it high
and kittle tried to catch it he got hit
low
and he injured his knee missed two games
he's full go after missing those games
could is this a week where i mean you
don't have jordan reed but you have ross
dwelling
is this a week against the eagles where
you really don't need
george kittle or is it better to just
throw him into the fray whenever he's
ready to go because of what he brings
from an intangible perspective i think
there's a little bit of that
there's no doubt and then the
play-making ability is too great
for him and especially that team right
now with like debo samuel who's just
starting to get out there and move
around and things like that raheem
mostert not there
kevin coleman not there so some of their
explosive playmakers are not you know
available
and that's where they miss them now last
week they got away with it
i mean shanahan was great in the drop
back passing game nick mullins was good
and then he had a few
good game plan design runs against the
giants defense that played the run
pretty well
you know and we saw brandon iuke i think
the silver lining is
they got to get some other guys some
reps the last two weeks to say
okay here you go so now when the other
guy's back you know we're gonna be
something to really work with here
because some of these young guys who
wouldn't have maybe got reps or got the
ball so much
did but kittle is too big of a
difference maker and this this eagles
defense as much as we talk about
carson wentz and the crap he's done the
eagles defense is playing pretty good
this year
and this will be a challenge for this
49ers offense and that's probably why he
wants kiddle out there as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports